росія травня сказала щось за барона меджлісу
так і ми і про мирне рішення
міжнародного суду оон
сюди покличу україни про ту Росію як це
адже травня було тисяча які шанси на вигляд
довго не роботу ми ж issue
механізм оповідання увальня за барона меджлісу
magic завирував і за рішенням поспішаю
верховного суду купати іншу владу криму
взводом верховного суду Росії позову
чим виступала так звана прокуратура пиво
островом на думку юристів самої він
прокуратура Росії might appear за датою
нові позов прослизання рішення
верховного суду у зв'язку з рішенням
міжнародного суду він суворий і виконаний
рішення міжнародного суду
ніби конана термін нового кінселу
рядок для око на ній рішення німа
я хочу москва за тяготами і час суд може
вирубати це рада bespeco він із праху
ним йде і вид по видиму резолюцію у
team москва може швидко ти себе
правом бета
з хмари ватої та шиви кінна росія
рішення його ці вагайся та там ще
moscow with новину роботу меджлісу
заявили тиснення ревнує його представляє
кого органу бац та іміджевих витрат на
кремля у Росії
проте на їх все кремль педана з то
на магатама зради такері замість
меджлісу
на лояльних до себе кримських татар від
спецслужби де я думати непрод
організації загалом у
а про те про креми активних людей
меджлісу дають гривні цвіте органу на
зливки не виконання
я хочу росіян та вигідне рішення
міжнародного суду про дружини
юридичних на зливки в ціни матами
у think ти можеш вбив пітер вати і
авторитет у міжнародному випив товар з
єдиний механізм вплинув його на росію нині з
завидної санкції